if you want to better understand
yourself and how to better interact with
others
you need to understand your values
that's why the minimalist created a
free downloadable and printable values
worksheet
that will help you identify all of your
different values
and the obstacles that are in your way
head on over to theminimalists.com
v to download your free values worksheet
today
enjoy non-minimalists
can the strength of one's immune system
be measured if so how
and what are she's asking for a top ten
let's not
necessarily say we have a top ten list
but what are some daily habits a human
can adopt to strengthen
his or her immune system
so is there a way to i mean how do we
measure the immune system i guess we're
looking at
inflammation as one way to look at the
immune system i mean there's tons of
measures there's inflammatory measures
there's antibody measures there's you
know there's all kinds of things that we
can measure for the immune system so
that's that's pretty
readily quantified i would offer and so
so what what tests do you ask your
doctor for if you're
if you're wanting to measure your immune
your immune system functionality
um you want to look at like um you want
to look at things like secretory iga or
iga
um you want to look at like very key
inflammatory markers you know
nothing to esoteric your crp and um
you know different measures like that is
the first things that i would go for
these are all blood tests by the way
yeah things that you can look at yeah
and so what are some daily habits
to answer becky's question here that we
can
use that we can implement to improve our
immune system in the long term yeah um
sleep and diet are kind of top two
really
so diet on a daily basis um
there's a pattern that i put forth in
the book which is not meant to be a diet
it's meant to be
a solution to a complex grouping of
problems which
is the real world circumstance we all
live in daily where
you get interrupted you get knocked off
course but then at the same time we have
this need to
restore things while we sleep and then
we have this need to
age better and all these things and that
that dietary pattern was my attempt at
answering that question the best way
that to my mind could possibly be done
which was to
provide balance in the diet but at the
same time
give a nod to sequencing uh
butyrate production while we sleep
repletion of nad
and very specific things through fasting
but not overly fasting
and then giving the body a break a few
times a week from insulin production
and activation of all the youth
extending pathways like the sirtuins and
amk
and so through the diet we have this
massive control switch
over immunity and and the things that
govern immunity and we can govern
we can govern the things that compromise
immunity so example
is um oxidative stress redox stress from
the foods we eat one thing people have
to realize is that
it doesn't matter what you eat it's
oxidative by its very nature so it's
called
oxidative metabolism the idea that
metabolism by its very nature is
oxidative there's a cost to eating and
once we understand what that cost is
we can sort of offset that cost by the
way we sequence and time foods so diet
is huge
sleep is the other um and then
there's kind of a third grouping of
things which really fall under replacing
things that we've lost
um one of those examples would be just
contact with dirt
yeah like like literally like like if
you garden if your hands get in the soil
there's some really fascinating new
research that shows
just getting your hands dirty for about
10 minutes a day
what happens is you literally get
bacterial transmission to the inner
organs from the skin
because the skin's one of the body's
biggest organs and so in the soil are
tens of thousands of microorganisms half
of which we haven't even quantified yet
our ancestors were merged with those
yeah and
so by just literally antigen sampling
and
by um taking in other strains of
bacteria we sort of merge with our
environment
so you could offer that our ancestors
probably had much more robust immune
systems than we do because we're so
hyper sanitized in fact
there's some fascinating research that
compares
the same ethnic populations one living
in finland where everything's
hypersanitized and hyper clean and you
know the dirt is removed
and then in russia where you have some
rural farmers and they're just they're
in the dirt all the time
and the the dirty farmers are way
healthier right yeah way healthier your
backs grew up
on a farm in minnesota and and i
i attribute a lot of her lifelong health
to
to that that i mean she she set herself
up oh her family
set herself up before yeah and
it's fascinating to me that there is
this you know what we've done
especially recently in our current times
and i understand the the the desire
to be safe but also we're
so hyper sterile that we're kind of
missing the point
very much so very much like um there's
such fascinating interesting research on
um eating dirt and being dirty and the
beneficial effects of that
um in fact there's really good research
on farm kids because they grow up in
an environment where essentially the
microorganisms are nebulized in the air
and they're breeding those in
and it affects their immunity they're
healthier wow because of that
so there's there's this category of
replacing back things that have been
lost it's the dirt it's the air it's the
sun it's all these sort of like you know
natural things that we
that we've just subtracted by virtue of
mechanization
and industrialization and covid and
staying indoors
and those things have a massive impact
on immunity massive and they're easy to
replace like literally just
gardening 10 minutes or putting your
hands in garden soil is huge
which is the opposite of what we're
doing now we are every place you turn
there's a hand sanitizer and
i've just heard horror stories of people
getting all warts on their hands and all
that because you're disrupting
people think of the the microbiome as
though it's something in the gup we also
have one on the skin right
huge and it's it's uh the research on
this is so compelling
um so when you garden or
you get your hands in the dirt and your
hands are in the dirt for let's say
10-15 minutes
and you go and wash your hands off you
don't eliminate the bacteria the
bacteria persists and then it actually
finds its way to your organs and
it improves immune function yeah yeah
and and and you can go down the list um
another example is just air
so we're in this you got to think about
something like with cova today
you have this you have this and this is
just it doesn't matter which position on
this is you just
all i'm saying is if you're in the
audience think this one through a little
bit um
most people today have issues with sleep
apnea okay like you're not getting
enough oxygen when you sleep okay that's
a cancer promoter it's like right at the
top list of cans promoting
then um depending on what you do you may
be spending a good chunk of your day
with a mask on yeah okay and you're not
getting exposed to the air you're
getting exposed to your own
your own breathing out your own cf2 um
so
you're essentially mimicking sleep apnea
during sleep during the during the day
uh there's a thing i have a course where
i talk about this
there's a thing called a re-oxygenation
injury and
i haven't heard this talked about
anywhere on the news and i'm blown away
by it
a re-oxygenation injury happens when you
go from
not getting enough oxygen and then
suddenly re-oxygenate
okay what happens is if you look at what
happens inside the cell
the cell goes from a state of
uh stabilized hif1
to introducing combustion back in the
cell okay through oxygenation
and essentially inside the cell it
injures the cell
so you get this prevalence of
inflammatory markers and
free radical production as a result of
re-oxygenating
so a good example this would be you wake
up in the morning
and you're really sore yeah a lot of
that and
the first half of the day you're super
sore a lot of that's a re-oxygenation
injury because you're not getting enough
oxygen at night you wake up you stop
your sleep apnea and now you're getting
this inflammatory storm in the body when
you re-oxygenate
so if you're constantly re-oxygenating
during the day after sustained periods
of not having oxygen
you should think that one through yeah
yeah it's fascinating
let's talk a bit about brain health and
how it relates to to gut health
i'm i'm thinking about we have uh
actually recording this before the
election but it's going to come out
after the election so this will be
fascinating oh my gosh
yeah and so you know this is obviously
isn't a political show but we have two
people who are running for president
or were running for president at this
point who
um they had cognitive
decline uh to be kind right
one probably worse than the other and i
and we we see this a lot as people age
obviously the cognitive decline of aging
now that's it seems to me that it's
potentially preventable
in many instances at least
but it probably starts with the gut
doesn't it
uh the gut has a lot
yes but not totally okay um there is a
component
um related from the health of the gut um
and you can you can sort of say this is
a x percent you know contributor to
cognitive decline
uh but it's not everything um cognitive
decline is multifactorial
and you see a lot of different um things
that contribute to the buildup of
amyloid plaques in the brain and
you know um the degradation of of
cognitive function
um it is much more ameliorateable than
probably we believe um just along the
way through
different types of protocols there's
even simple things that are available
now like mushrooms that have been shown
to help you know with cognitive decline
so um as much as we is you know being a
guy as much as i would like to say it's
all the gut it's not right no but i i
have noticed that a lot of people when
they
start to make those changes and they go
with one of these sort of experimental
diets the elimination diets
uh one thing that people often report
myself included
is more mental clarity less brain fog
so there seems to be some sort of
correlation there right can we talk
about why
why that is why why might the food that
we eat calls us
to have brain fog well um as we age
there's a there's a very good argument
that alzheimer's is the third form of
diabetes
okay oh wow that really what it is is
it's a problem of glucose transport in
the brain
and the way the brain is using sugar is
basically impaired so and
think of it like you know what if what
if you know you had
like central obesity what if you had
that in the brain
and the brain just didn't use sugar the
way it was supposed to then what you
would find
is that when you shift inputs and
substrates of things and then the brain
begins burning ketones it's like the
lights go back on
okay suddenly things are working well
it's because you've got a dual drive
system
that powers the car and the gas engine
system's not working very well
and then what you find is when you shift
to the electric drive things seem to go
better
okay so that's that's partially an
answer for it um the other answer has to
do with
if the gut's not working properly and
you're
you've got issues related to the
absorption of nutrients and inflammatory
markers
then the brain is sort of in this
constantly inflamed state
what you'll see you'll see in particular
issues with different aspects of the
brain
that can become inflamed a good example
is in the hypothalamus
there is a key area called the archaic
nucleus and there's these things called
a goodie related proteins in there
when the hypothalamus gets inflamed in
that area um
then you'll see outcomes like
dysregulation of eating patterns and you
know you just can't stop eating and all
that and it has to do with inflammation
in the brain
specifically so those things can be
affected by diet
dramatically yeah um so it's a complex
question the just can't stop eating
thing is fascinating because
quite often going back to the gut there
one of the reasons that we
crave a particular type of food a lot of
it has to do with
the bugs that are in the gut right let's
talk about that
yeah it's fascinating um and so i i get
into this
thing in the book that um you know again
i hope i made the case for this
and it's that um your cravings are
highly steerable
like like your cravings are not even you
you think it's you but it's really them
they've hijacked you
and they want you to feed them what they
want
so what you see a lot of is people who
like you know like common
common thing when you deal with
dietetics is like i just have these crab
cravings they gave me and i can't shut
them off
and it's like you don't have carb
cravings in the evening
they do and they want you to feed them
and they've hijacked your your vagus
nerve and your machinery and they're
getting you to feed them so when you go
to sleep they can multiply
the coolest thing about all this is how
rapidly steerable all this
is like i've seen out there you know
like entire courses dedicated to
crushing cravings and all trying to push
them aside
there's 100 no need to do that you can
steer your cravings you can make
yourself crave whatever you want to
crave
just by building that bacteria up in the
gut and i've done it many many times
i've done it with lots of people
so instead of crazy craving cheesecake
you could crave
fruits 100 i just did that one um i've
got i've got a client who
um uh suddenly was just
couldn't get enough fruit couldn't get
enough blackberries couldn't get enough
raspberries and
um this where this gets really
interesting is when you look at
pregnancy and transgenerational
epigenetics
if you're eating the right things during
pregnancy you can make your kid be born
craving those things
wow yeah it's it's fascinating like you
want you want to eat like a lot of
spinach for your cr
your kid will be born craving spinach um
and it's it's super fascinating
yeah but but in the more immediate now
um
you can gosh um we did these engagements
with hospitals a few years back and we
had all these medical professionals we
actually filmed these um i think they're
on our site you can go see them
and sites veep nutrition deep
nutrition.com yeah
and you'll see their testimony of like i
don't crave those things anymore i get
nauseated when i eat them
and now i'm craving this and it's all by
just changing communities in the gut
in fact what you'll see happen is once
the gut communities have been changed
and then you eat that thing you used to
crave
you'll get super nauseated typically and
the reason is that
you're giving substrate to the old bad
guys and you're getting a rebloom of
them and you're getting a die off of
some of the good guys and then
the the in the die off their guts break
open they spill lipopolysaccharide into
the gut
and then that's causing nausea it's the
same thing that happens when a fever
breaks
and so you get real nausea and feel sick
and like i don't want that stuff anymore
wow and so yeah you can completely steer
cravings and you can do it fast
very fast i uh i went on a vacation a
little while back
and um i kept doing the red phenols on
the vacation because i just we were just
you know literally eating on the road
like
7 11 you know every 10 miles and um what
i found at the end of it was i came back
just
craving like fibers and and just because
i had so much red phenols